you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network or are you
Aaron or are they professional this is a
bi-racial American history podcast now
each week I man with knees lover of all
dogs sometimes roller on the grass what
are you Dave Anthony what's your
property's a story from American history
family to his nemesis no idea what the
topic is give me about it I'm not your
nemesis stop saying that you don't get
to choose I look at you choose if you're
my nemesis I choose my nemesis I just
think it's a weird choice really yes
it's a very weird choice you think about
all the [ __ ] you've put me through what
have I done to you called it quote is
jam-packed champ and I'm the [ __ ]
limo guy Dave okay names Garrity but
it's good and this is not gonna come you
both resent sick arguments my friend
yes dear what do you do
September 12th at 10:00 p.m. we'll be at
the Westside comedy theater and then we
have shows this weekend right Dave yeah
we'll be in Sacramento on Friday and
we'll be in Boise on Saturday we'll be
in Madison on October 18th in Milwaukee
on October 20th September 28th at 10:00
p.m. I'll be at the main room and
flappers or at flappers and then uh
there's one other one yes sir no we're
gonna be in Europe we're gonna be in
Stockholm Oslo Amsterdam at Glasgow
Manchester London Birmingham Cardiff
Dublin and Copenhagen might be a couple
shows being at it yeah yeah so what do
you think about that everybody yeah
October 2nd I'll be at the Venice
underground in Venice California
hey you made it Venice yes sure it's a
big deal that's huge I mean I got on the
10 and I was like I'm here it's crazy
thank you for your support we should
also mention that we have a like a ten
part or dollop episodes called the
dollop England and the UK which is their
stories are pretty insane if you guys
like Dallas ODEs that are insane that's
those are the ones them ones yeah so we
are brought to you by liquid I V liquid
IV is the fastest most efficient way to
stay hydrated you're trying to drink
more water liquid IV hydrates you two to
three times faster and more efficiently
than water alone with an added bonus of
vitamin C b3 b5 b6 and b12 a lot of the
beasts I take a lot of the B's a lot of
the bass I take those when I travel yes
it's a very good to hydrate after I
gotta say the last time I traveled
internationally I took these and I feel
like it made it here yeah they do
liquid IV prevents jet lag when
traveling well there we go
that was coming CSA friendly and it's
perfect for on-the-go travelers helps to
keep your skin hydrated while flying can
be used before during after flights so
yeah you didn't know that was coming
down there it was I've been using a lot
I've been working out a lot so I've been
drinking drinking drinking I like it
yeah it's the fastest-growing wellness
brand you can find them everywhere even
Costco you can find their hydration
multiplier sold at Costco's nation wide
non-gmo vegan free free of gluten dairy
and soy clean ingredients a healthy
alternative to traditional sugary sports
drinks know what official flavors or
preservatives here that traditional yaps
drinks right in your whole drink whole
don't try convenient as we said TSA
friendly power packs for travel helps
with jet lag I'm a bit like I said I'm a
big fan I've been using it and I use a
lot Dave they're in my suitcase someone
was like hey you guys shouldn't be you
guys shouldn't be selling a product
advertising a product that actually
people use as IVs and I had to say no
it's the name yeah we're not actually
time we're not suggesting this goes into
your veins that's not been suggested I
was like no it's a it's a drink yeah
it's a drink for your blood I love
liquid IV and I know you will too right
now our listeners to get 25% off at a
liquid IV calm when you use our code
dollop a checkout that's 25% off
anything you order on liquid IVs website
go to liquid IV com enter our promo code
dollop to get your savings and start
getting better hydration that's liquid
IV com promo code dollop don't wait
start properly hydrating today we also
brought to you by fabfitfun fabfitfun
box time is that the song I don't think
they have a song and I know they don't
know fabfitfun is a women's lifestyle
subscription box with full size a
premium Beauty lifestyle fitness home
and wellness products sent straight to
your doorstep each season they take the
hassle out of shopping by doing it for
you each box boxes
customize for your specific interests
and they deliver this seasonal
must-haves that you need my wife loves
it my huge fan I'm starting to just love
it she takes it and squirrels it away
and I don't see it yeah I don't see
anymore there's private unpacking around
there's a room she does it under a sheet
Heather that's going on the boxes saw it
fast so you should send it today you
know so it's really great so they also
give they also help support female
founded companies and charities a lot of
the products in the box are from female
found companies and each season
fabfitfun partners with a non-profit to
raise funds and awareness look I got fit
fund box that's right they got a lot of
great products just not like sample size
stuff it's real size it's actual yeah
like true no it's like three $250 worth
of stuff and you get it for whatever
it's great that was really good
I don't know the numbers I don't have
the thing in front of me I do but I
don't see it anyway yeah it's like it's
like hundred more money with the value
you're getting it for your and it's true
yeah it has a retail value over 200
bucks you're getting it for $49.99 I
mean that's that's right there be happy
be happy
Thanks you know have fun with it
okay my wife got a shawl and I wear it
yeah my wife to just the shawl she wears
the show all the time I wear your wife
shawl I know she was real she'd be
furious I'm furious it's also a guys
it's a great gift thing for your lady
also fabfitfun is a seasonal
subscription box with a full-size Beauty
Fitness fashion and lifestyle products
it retails for $49.99 but always have
about has a value over $200 a bit I was
saying about that's it
use code dollop for $10 off your first
box at WWF uncom that's $10 off your
first box use code dollop and go to fat
WWF at fifa.com
boom boom boom we did it we made it all
happen guys we also brought to you by
zipper cord zipper unzipping cord and
zip recorder guys we also brought to you
by zip
recruiter hiring can be a very slow
process take Alturas CEO Dylan Miska
whit's he needed to hire a director of
coffee for his organic coffee company
but he was having trouble finding
qualified applicants so he switched to
zip recruiter and zip recruiter doesn't
depend on candidates finding you it
finds them for you it's technology
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply it
to your job so you get qualified
candidates first Dylan posted his job on
zip recruiter and he was impressed by
how quickly he had great candidates
apply he also used dipper Critters
candidate rating feature to filter his
applicants so he could focus on the most
relevant ones and that's how Dylan found
his new director of coffee in just a few
days yeah yeah with results like that
it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
boom I didn't even know there was a
director of coffee and the things we've
learned all the time there you go direct
your coffee it's not something I I don't
even drink coffee so I am not I'm not
gonna be on that list well if there's a
director of iced tea guess who's there
nobody should be a director of iced tea
just it doesn't matter but I want that
job now but this is about him I know CY
zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free at our web address
zip recruiter comm slash dollop that zip
recruiter comm slash dollop do llo p zip
recruiter comm a slash dollop zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire and
them I might I might hire you at some
point I would love to leave the intern
role I would we'll see okay but you're
like when you're when I put that upon
zipper core just make sure that your
your you know yeah resume resume
we are also brought to you by
Squarespace
Squarespace of course is a company that
helps you build a beautiful website they
host it hang out all the templates
it's all happening oh yeah we both use
it for our personal websites our comedy
websites we use it for our sources we
use it for our regular website we use
that's it that's all the websites in our
life I don't think we have any other
ones so they're all with Squarespace so
you can turn a cool idea into a website
you can check is you working in blogger
publish content you can sell products
and services of all kinds promote your
physical online building a business look
they've got beautiful templates like I
said you want to go in there you want to
build a nice website see how it feels
get in there do it check it out ours is
beautiful beautiful relaxed he has the
ability to customize look and feel
settings products and more with just a
few clicks it's a new way to buy domains
and choose from over 200 extensions got
analytics built in search engine
optimization free and secure hosting
24/7 award-winning support I'm telling
you you gotta get it I mean even if you
don't want a website I'm telling you to
get that Squarespace there's be a weird
move but okay so check out
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch use the
offer code dollop to save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
that squarespace.com enter code dollop
who who named this podcast you named it
hmm really that's right
I just showed up to your garage one day
and you were like I'm sorry you're gonna
do the dollar
hey just apologize yeah every money look
we always do we don't always make great
choices in life I feel like it was a
good move calling her the dollop yeah
why what about history time
that's grave and Gareth Gareth with Dave
and Gary that's right
sometimes you forget your nemesis yeah
just some side of your brain 1786 okay
or 1792 all right somewhere in there
okay Murray I Oh II was born into the
Iowa Tribe okay possibly in st. Louis in
the Missouri area in there sure when she
was still a teenager she married a
Pierre Dorian junior okay
Pierre was the son of the French
impersonator sorry interpreter Oh Dave
you know which one I wanted to be oh
that's right they bought it
gentlemen they bought it again the
French interpreter who traveled with
Lewis and Clark on their expedition
uh-huh so Pierre senior was French
Creole starting to worry that he's not
French what too big too small what do
you ask there huh
me in the fresh I'm an interpreter for
God's sake
Pearson your was French Creole a
descendant of the Acadians who we met on
a previous episode he traveled the
western frontier and spent time with
different Native American tribes he
married a Sioux woman and they had
children one of whom was pure junior so
Irving uh
I should say that in Washington Irving
wrote a lot of this okay so he wrote
that father and son would sometimes
drink together and then get in fights
when they got older now juice sure no
baby
yeah well would not surprise me anyway
Pierre jr. often won those fights okay
if you can beat a Brill man that's cool
yeah well you don't have that addiction
to alcohol that he has so you can just
get a buzz where is he's like honey did
not remember this Pierre jr. grew up
married a woman from the Yankton tribe
named holy rainbow nice all right that
name came from it's like the guy that
saw the double rainbow whole guy that
guy's the best fast double rainbow guy
and the best part I think is I believe
at one point he thinks it might be a
triple rainbow yeah that's right well a
fleeting moment there is a second thing
it's almost a triple rose more of a
double so then he then Peter jr.
abandoned holy rainbow he was out okay
she was out of him his second wife he
married again Marie she was about five
feet five inches tall kind and very
patient they had two sons jean-baptiste
and Paul great French sure yeah Pierre
was looking for work as a guide or
interpreter looks like his dad an
impersonator or impersonate right
John Jacob Astor wanted to establish a
fur trading post at the mouth of the
Columbia River okay
Astor had made a fortune from killing
animals for their fur around the Great
Lakes awesome I put that part in but
that's what it is it's great yeah so he
was just doing like a apocalypse of
beavers it's very cool now he wanted to
do the same thing on the coast of Oregon
and hoped to control the fur trade with
Asia okay it's great right can send you
can send animals skin over to another
country fantastic
the expedition Pierre got a job on that
was to identify locations for fur
trading posts so Astor created the
Pacific Fur Company in June 1810 he
managed the business from New York and
he sent two groups out west one by sea
on the ship Tonkin
with supplies and people to start
trading and then another group were to
go buy land and set up four posts on the
way and then they would meet at the
place the boat guys had set up okay I
want the boat job I've been little guys
guys for sure guys all day long yeah
she's got one fur trade imposed to worry
about yep yeah
the expedition left st. Louis and was
led by Wilson hunt who had zero
experience traveling in the wilderness
but his name's hunt or trading with
Native American oh it's just a gut it's
a family yeah you wouldn't understand
you're in Anthony I don't know I don't I
don't know this case like a bloodhound
my name is you get him out there and
he's just like and he knows the wild is
six cents yeah he's like a wolf boy yeah
yeah he just gets out there and all the
sudden yeah so you don't need like any
experience or knowledge or anything like
my last name Reynolds nobody can deal
with leftovers better and I didn't know
that when I had the mayor it was just
when someone was like oh we're gonna
toss this quiche I go you don't need to
toss it and I put a bunch of foil around
the thing that it was in and I put it in
the fridge then you know what happened
two days later the miracle what day a
more the quiche Wow
it's like the oil since I'm Hanukkah I
don't know sometimes the stories are bad
the one well you what you've looked got
it right a lot of these GE Pierre was
picked because he was good at business I
mean hunt was pick because he was good
at business okay that's the guy eating
tape it it make sense it makes sense
yeah okay and hunt was only 29 years old
so this is the guy yeah young and
experienced he's got a business mind get
him near trees graduated from Dartmouth
perfect ready to go yeah yeah let him be
the one who tells you how to build a
shelter so the main trading post at the
Fork of the Missouri River was
continually harassed by Blackfeet so
much so that the commander mr. Henry had
to abandon the posts crossed the Rocky
Mountains in order to set up a new
trading post along the Columbia River
nobody knew what had become of him okay
so he was working for that was sorry
that's the rival trading company it was
to training camp okay so the first one
is the Pacific Fur Company it's the one
that they're going to set out
right and he's his one is which one this
is this is mr. Henry okay and mr. Henry
has set up I think it's the British for
company it doesn't matter because they
don't end up being around very much okay
but it's a rival company sure and so
this guy set up a fort then the natives
were like hey what if you're not here
uh-huh
and he bails right no one knows where he
went okay so the worry was that he'd
been killed by you know Native Americans
sure so Han arrives in st. Louis it
would be great if like in the pelts they
just saw hunt skin oh dear Lord well I
think we found out it's just a face just
training him some guy you know some guys
just go wearing it over yeah sure I'll
tell you this thing really keeps the
warmth in I don't know what's going on
and then it's got this hood feature
oh god that's hot yeah yeah no I am
aware but if you see we've cut this job
out oh so it's kind of like a hoodie hey
hey watch this heard only in the
expedition through the woods I'm a
businessman I do everything I'm just
kidding it's still me under here I like
it it will take time yeah well
unfortunately oh god what I do hurts me
Larry
a kidding it's me again hey Larry's been
dead for a week so so hunt rises saying
Louis Henry Henry worked for the
Missouri fur trading coming that's the
rival Pacific Trading fur trading
company Missouri okay they're both just
killing animals sure that's great doing
stuff right selling it that's cool you
can just go out nature and kill
something and sell it
well because it's yours yeah it's not
like it belongs to nature now the new
because you found it no need to kill it
no treat it like a shopping spree take
everything leave a husk that's right
so he is hunt is preparing an expedition
and also another man for the Missouri
fur trading company is preparing an
expedition mr. Manuel Lisa okay mr. Lisa
that's right and he's gonna go look for
mr. Henry okay
I was very unusual for there to be two
expeditions at the same time but you
know the competitors be competing and
they're both going to set up trading
posts yeah okay but in the same area
what one is going where mr. Henry flea
the other one is going there with the
purpose right so it caused a big demand
for hunters and
fleurs who who worked the competing
situations for higher pay and advances
quote the greatest difficulty was to
find a su interpreter there was one man
at st. Louis a half-breed named Pierre
Dorian okay there's our boy yeah Pierre
had worked things called the half-breed
yeah this I had to cut out a lot of
[ __ ] endless found the literature of
the past every night sighs every time
there's a quote it's like I get it I get
it I get he had what that means period
worked for the Missouri for company the
year before and was a very good employee
okay when sober sure okay so the fights
with dad the drug lights they paid off
sure but he liked to drink a lot and
when he did his bad side came out I got
I liked that Pierre potentially a bad
hire quote oh no it's bad Pierre what
did you want [ __ ] you quote while
working for the Missouri company on the
frontier he had been seized with a
whiskey mania he by the way something
you hear a lot and it's time to change
the name black out to whiskey you
blacked out at the wedding
I didn't black out I had whiskey mania I
mean that's what we should start a new
podcast whiskey mania hey we just drink
whiskey sure oh my god
and since that'll be history time yeah
Oh God
and since the beverage could only be the
body when we rip off our own podcast
well then we'd be ripping off drunk
history right which is a great podcast
for people that are like parents to
watch right and since the beverage could
only be brought at the company store it
had been charged to his account at the
rate of ten dollars a quart okay that's
it so it's a company store whiskey he
likes to drink he's been running up a
tab so he's just running he's drinking
okay ten bucks a quart
that's a lot his debt was not paid and
this became a heated disagreement
because he no one works for the company
right just the mention of the dispute
sent peer into a rage okay
so he's he's sensitive about his
drinking problem
yeah that's what sounds like yeah mr.
Lisa's threats over the whiskey debt
drove Pierre to work for the rival
Pacific fur trading company mr. hunt
it's interesting when your job
decision-making is based on whiskey
access and whiskey debt and whiskey debt
and the debt you proof-of-work death he
negotiated a very good deal with mr.
hunt $300 for a year 200 to be paid in
advance okay
Pierre now had a job as a guide and
interpreter heading to the Pacific coast
it ran in the family as a dad had worked
for Lewis and Clark as she said but just
when hunts group was about to leave
st. Louis five American hunters arrived
and alleged they had been treated poorly
by asters company okay they refused to
travel with mr. hunt and told all the
others about the suffering and dangers
they had faced on their expedition this
caused all the hunters who had signed on
with hunt to panic okay
I sighs I sniff some theatrics well then
you had to pay them all more okay oh
well yeah so they all go but the first
once you get down the river y'all gonna
have to pass the Cerebrus what the
Cerebus Serapis yes I'm sorry I'd like a
three-headed dog but it's got riddle
kill ask riddles it's in s riddles yeah
it's a three-headed dog that ice riddle
that's right and it's down down down by
the river yeah and it don't pat what
down by the river yeah yeah and if you
get past that you got to have sex with
the fish man he's half man half fish but
it's not in the way where you'd picture
to be like a mermaid or something where
he's got like half of his bottom it's
like every four inches of scaler skin
and it keeps alternating it looks like
zebra stripes so you get past Cerebus
with riddle what about I then you got to
go to fish man you have sex with fish
man about this fish man have a part or
fish man has all the parts
he's got fish and man parts okay see
figure out my advisor big old you know
did you have sex with fish man I
had sex with fish man not this one so
there's other fishermen out there
I'm a regular traveler I go through a
lot of this you know we've met we've
never heard anything about this
really that's crazy but then once you
get past fish man know what you gotta do
I spend a night in the Haunted drawer
okay so we're just gonna take off we're
not really buying the whole thing
anymore like times you take it too far
give me $50 well you tell me this
where's the haunted drawer there's an in
Wyoming like where's the haunted drawer
it's in well it's like a duck comes out
of the side of a mountain my husband a
drawer work what's comes out side of
mountain and then what happens what's
your next kiss and then you get in it
that's right and then someone closes the
drawer and then you're in the mountain
yeah you spend that in it but it ain't
no regular night
no why not we're gonna Jordan Mountain
stupid was with this guy I don't think
he's ready to lead y'all okay okay so
yeah look I'm a businessman and I know I
know bullshitters and I think you're
full of [ __ ] I don't think this is
three-headed dog I don't think there's a
fish guy with a dick you don't think
this fish man yeah I definitely don't
think there's a drawer a haunted drawer
not just a drawer okay yeah more party
mister I see you later see you later
clown face there are clown faces and you
have one I know hardcore I'm really came
at you yeah clown face so um anyway that
are you leaving I just don't know what
to do that okay I walk this way then
okay I'll see y'all later
sorry I thought the bit was over and
then I was still here so I didn't even
know I'll see you later
so Pierre made a deal he would get on
the boat and he was the first guy to
make a deal
if mr. hunt agreed to let him take his
wife Marie and their two kids okay who
were like two and five great perfect age
to pass away on a boat that's what yeah
like she must have been like wait now
how is that the deal I figured it out
you can come with us all right I've sex
when I'm out hunting and doing
when I'm traveling dangerous mountains
and through horrible streams and
fighting bears I want to hey what's
wrong what a [ __ ] plus my whiskey mania
kicks in quote the evening after they
left the fur expedition so all the other
guys signed back on learned that a
warrant had been issued against a peer
Dorion for his whiskey debt with his
whiskey is really chasing him and mr.
Lisa intended to entrap the interpreter
upriver at st. Charles so Pierre heard
about the warrant on the way up on the
on the boat and he he takes off they let
him off the boat he takes his family
gets off and he heads into the forest
well and again for the family probably
cool yeah the family probably exciting
to know that the original plan that was
a little off kilter has now been thrown
out the window and now it's just time to
get off the boat and run into the middle
of the forest with your two-year-old
yeah it's not look I feel really cool I
feel he's not the best family man it's
like accidental camping who doesn't want
to do that it's yeah it's like
accidental camera yeah so so he takes
off and they the boat the boat their
owns boat goes on I'm probably again a
really good feeling for the life she's
loving this like the boats gone it's
official were just here he's got no plan
he had no plan total freedom and we're
doing this because he drank too much
whiskey that's right we're in the woods
now because of his whiskey with our
children because he caused the whiskey
deaths so high they're going to entrap
him Murray was quote laden with their
pupusas and a large bundle containing
the most precious effects promising they
would rejoin them some distance later
the expedition party reached st. Charles
in the afternoon
of course hunt sorry Pierre was not on
board right the lawmen did not find
Pierre in st. Charles the boats
continued the next morning they had not
gone far when Pierre appeared on the
shore okay no yes we hate the middle one
alone
boy they took him back on board and
apparently things had not gone well with
his wife while they were out in the
woods now Dave it let me tell you a
place where you're not allowed to tell
your wife or your children that they're
stressing you out a little bit and leave
them is when you're in the forest huh on
a whiskey run okay go ahead when you're
when you're basically trying to hear you
but I kind of don't on the whiskey lamb
and you're abandoned your family because
they were probably annoying you about
what you've done look you're out there
and they're like I'm cool yeah and
you're just like ah ah shut up
so yes so what had happened was they had
gotten into a fight probably if she
didn't want to be out in the woods
always probably sore about having to get
off the boat and go to the woods so what
happened was he quote they had a quarrel
the night Pierre had administered the
Indian discipline of the cudgel which
means he beat her with some sort of
stick she didn't dig that and she took
off into the woods with their kids and
all their stuff oh my god transaction
chin like that yeah
Pierre apparently felt think about how
big of a douchebag you have to be for
your wife to run off in the forest we're
gonna go this way yeah maybe we'll find
a better husband I didn't look up if
that's like a real thing but I've never
heard of that with Native Americans I'm
sure it was just him being a [ __ ]
douche bag right right
although there's right here something
called the burro cudgel but who knows so
so Perry Pierre feels terrible as every
[ __ ] jackass who shares life does oh
now I feel bad
he's upset she's gone she also took his
knapsack which was upsetting to sure so
but hunt could not wait for a marital
issue to resolve and they moved on and
they take Pierre and they move on yeah
right
that night Pierre leave his wife and
Jill there's nothing because they don't
know if she's ever gonna come back
you know they can't you know I don't
know good time is money right sure that
night Pierre said he slept terribly
upset by what he had done but before
sunrise he heard Marie calling from the
shore Marie had been wandering in the
woods all night looking for the party
and she eventually found them because of
their fires the expedition continued on
as she got on the boat the expedition
continued on but they're very heavy very
rains making it slow and dangerous
so the party continued to grow as other
boat crews join them so by April there
were 26 people that part I don't really
understand but I guess that's what it's
like on the river out in the middle of
nowhere well there's a bunch of water
you just you just roll up in together
can we go on your expedition to kill
beavers yeah yeah come on out here
floating around yeah yes normal we're
normal all right guys I trust you
looking to hook up with some other guy
yeah we're all here having a good old
time I'm out on a boat we're not gonna
kill you at night now that'll do that we
could be VIRs sure we're not gonna hit
you in the head and drop you off the
side of the boat any chance we get and
we're no way we're not too worried up
here I'll tell you that much this guy
left his wife and kid in the forest
today so you know we're we're on you
we're not the best either I don't think
you should complement about that but I
gotta get out of here boys I don't know
how things work let me show you what we
put most of the valuables it's right
here in the middle a lot of the stuff
here weapon I like visualize me hitting
you with a club right above well that
reminds me this is where we keep the
clubs and they come in varying size you
get small I got medium large
this is a big ones watch you bleed yeah
you could do that and then yeah here's
rags clean up the murder whatever it is
whatever you're into leave you to the
fish man sure however you guys feel like
doing it it's just nice to have company
fish being a hump you yeah that's a fish
babies me sure oh okay
more of the
which guy stuff well whatever
so they went they found a friendly
Native American village now they were
given meals and a party was held after
the party
they left the next day and a commotion
broke out sure
turns out Murray enjoyed being at the
village and wanted to stay there inch of
course of course pair with us you know
what had happened what there's an option
B yeah anything better anything but
going ever it is going off but there's
no other women on this boat let me tell
you twenty-five dudes and a lady by the
way great movie god terrible nightmare
nightmare but also she just chose to go
to the forest alone she didn't choose
well yeah she didn't want to go in the
forest alone
right but she told when she went away
from him yeah yeah when she ran no this
is a much more enticing option it's
imagine what should let people let's
take let's take the wilderness out of
this sure let's just go with the twenty
five dudes and a lady on a boat yes
you're out yes
as a lady you're out yes so uh yes your
entire mean you might you're just
getting I [ __ ] all day by these yeah
she want and she wants to stay with
these nice Native American people she
just meant and Pierre was not down with
that and he forced her on the boat he
was possibly a little drunk when he did
it I assume she probably didn't want to
make the trip because it turns out she
was three months pregnant
Oh God oh my god what you don't want to
go off into the forest when you're three
months pregnant uh hang around this time
the ship Astor had sent right yeah the
other by sea the Tonkin arrived and
established the Trading Post Astoria on
point George on the southern shore of
the Columbia so everything's going
according to plan over there right but
soon after the captain of the ship who
everyone [ __ ] hated everybody hates
the captain sure took the ship on a
trading mission to Vancouver I mentioned
everyone hates the captain right but yes
through everybody for sure nobody likes
the captain
so he takes the ship after they set up
his fort and he heads up to trade with
the climate people now I think they're
in candidate
Vancouver's but they couldn't come to
terms over a trade okay
so captain thorn slapped the elder who
was doing the trading of indigenous
person who handled the negotiation with
a fir in the face oh boy that's so I
would say I'm just I think a bad move
personally so it turns out they didn't
like that uh-huh
for some reason and soon there was an
attack on the ship the warriors killed
most of the crew a few survived and ran
off but they were also killed the next
day the warriors returned to plunder the
ship there was one guy on the ship hey
hi hey justice so hey do you guys want
everything I'm I'm alive James and I
would like to stay alive James anywho I
wish we had an interpreter I feel weird
so anyway he learns them onto the ship
okay healers all these you know native
guys on the ship Salish and then he
lights the Gunpowder magazine and blows
up the ship so he lured 200 Salish
natives on and and killed them by
blowing up the ship Wow the only crew
member who survived was an interpreter
who had relatives among the clay quat so
not a great start to the everything yeah
Wow
so that's not going to good either now
the land expedition looks great right
and that's one terrible yeah hunts party
had more men join up and now they were
60 ma so I they're just picking up dudes
in the middle of nowhere I don't know
what happens out there I mean you would
need to vet someone mildly out like
filling it turning it into a party boat
five were partners with Astor one was a
clerk 40 were Canadian of voyagers hired
boat men and several were hunters they
were on four boats one was large enough
to mount
swivel gun and two howitzers Wow so
they're going into the forest ready yeah
I mean they're not [ __ ] around they
pitched tents at night and told stories
and sang songs around campfires great
that's nice sure it's a trip the party
started to rest in a friendly Omaha
village sorry stayed to rest in a
friendly Omaha village there were then
three Sioux arrived and warned that
another band of Sioux nearby were
preparing to attack the chief of the
Omaha's returned from hunting and said
two men had just been killed by a band
of Sioux yeah obviously I was freaking
out now especially the Voyageurs the
Canadian voyagers boya gears I know what
Canadians College quote the Canadians
pictured to themselves bands of fierce
warriors stationed along each bank of
the river by whom they would be shot
down in their boats or lurking hordes
who would set them set on them at night
and Massacre them and their encampments
some of the Canadians wanted to turn
back around and three deserted into the
woods that's yeah this because then you
have to walk through there's people who
live there you get to why you're like
you got to hope that everyone's like
come on through my yard your guy for in
Jason movies
you really are it's like we don't follow
you when you go into the woods we find
you so as they traveled on the boats
many of the Canadians who were now very
afraid watched the river's edge but
there were no sooo the Canadians still
started to worry about an ambush at
every turn quote the very name Sioux
became a watchword of Terror an elk a
wolf or any other animal would appear on
the hills and the boats sounded with
shouts from and n voila lassoo voila
nice ooh they are singing there soon
ooh-la-la of a cool little mask
Benjen finally they did come across a
band of hostile Sioux quote oh thank god
here the swivel gun and howitzers were
loaded with powder and fired to let the
savages know by the sound how formidable
E they were armed
the noise echoed along the shores of the
river and must have startled the Indian
warriors who were only accustomed to the
shots of rifles but the minions remained
and watched them in silence they're
painted bodies and faces glaring in the
Sun and their feathers fluttering in the
breeze when the boats were within rifle
range
the hunters prepared to shoot but there
was a confused look on the Native
American faces and they displayed their
buffalo robes raised them with both
hands of other heads and then spread
them in front of them on the ground
Pierre Dorian started yelling out not to
shoot because this is a sign they were
peaceful and wanted to meet okay
so the Americans came in kind of hot
some real heating's Americans just came
rolled in like dick heads yeah unusual
yeah the Native American warriors lit a
fire on the edge of the river and held
the peace pipe ceremony okay
mr. hunt then gay made a speech in
French which Pierre interpreted hunt
told the Sioux they were not looking to
trade with any tribes upriver or just
tossing just tossing the mountains to
look for some other look for some of
their fellow countrymen who had been
gone for 11 months he was lying he made
that all up they were not for anybody
okay
I knew was gonna trade with anybody
upstream I liked the idea I do I am
picturing Pierre drunk every time you
interpret for the record yeah it's gotta
be okay yeah hunt ended up giving them
tobacco and corn super happy with a
delicious combination yeah oh my god
nothing goes better with a mouthful of
corn than a big sucker tobacco the sewer
hats actually vape flavor now isn't it
tobacco corn wow that's great
super happy with this and said the
reason for their hostile gathering was
to prevent guns from going to the
ricarose Mandans and minnetarees
tribes whom they were at war with but
now they were like yeah good and pass if
you're not gonna give any stuff cruise
on through quote the white hunters in
the expedition group continued to be for
of wandering in this dangerous
neighborhood and fresh provisions began
to be scarce in the camp therefore as a
substitute for venison and buffalo meat
the travelers had to purchase a number
of dogs to be shot and cooked
fortunately the Indians were generous
with their dogs great I mean everybody
wins yeah well well not the dog the dogs
lose but everyone else wins yeah
everyone else tummy full absolutely in
fact these animals swarm about Indian an
Indian village as they do about a
Turkish town so it's pretty cool to hit
two different ethnic groups at once it's
fun sentence right I mean yeah every
family has two or three dozen belonging
to it of all sizes and colors some of a
superior breed are used for hunting
others to draw the sleds and others
snack dogs of a Mongol breed and an idol
vagabond nature are fattened for food
eating dogs well that makes sense
so you got the quality sure you got your
good dog right right and then you got
like a nice one for the sleds yeah and
then they came across another tribe we
were very happy that the white men
wanted to trade and they promised to
provide beaver skins actually just here
for more dog we really haven't gotten a
taste for sure oh my god we won Sona dog
do you have any scrappers during one
evening pair and two hunters went
missing and did not return by Sunrise mm
the group thought they had wandered off
after Buffalo and we're not that
concerned because they knew they would
easily be able to track the party they
left a fire burning to guide the three
men and they had it out and then it
began to rain and the debt general gloom
came over the men now they're worried
that they lost the guys
the Canadians sat in groups smoking him
muttering and then they heard the shouts
as peer and the two other men arrived
back quote they came slowly lagging into
camp with weary looks and their hunting
excursion on the prairies they had
pushed so far and pursued a buffalo and
found it impossible to retrace their
steps over the plains yeah I mean just
like probably one of those things are
you just assuming it's I mean
essentially what it is is it's like
history's parking garage it's like you
know you're not focused on anything
other than the mission and then
the sudden when the mission is over or
incomplete and it's time to call it
you're like what floor number I remember
nothing even Murray was happy to see
Pierre oh yeah so they moved on after a
few days they said a group of warriors
they saw a group of warriors coming over
a bank and gathering on the shore it was
a war party they were armed with bows
and arrows and battle clubs and their
bodies painted black and white stripes
mr. hunts boat was in front and the
closest but it passed near them without
any problems then all the warriors ran
along the bank until they were opposite
to the boats and they threw aside their
weapons and waded in to the boats and
surrounded the boats and then they
reached out to shake hands because they
knew this is how the white men like to
show they were friends every every every
introduction or every well no ideas two
sides are coming like you have to know
ID you're like what are we doing here
are we murder each other are we trading
what's the deal what what's happening
I mean we were hoping to trade and
murder is that cold they we're gonna
wanna do a further give you some other
people but the Native Americans went
over the top of the handshaking quote
they carried it to an extreme all right
that's nice
that's a gentleman yeah we're know we're
doing setup gentlemen it's like one it's
like one-two punch why don't you pump
some we know that's enough all right
your head four to five times you
especially a workout all right my arms
are hurting so they're obviously not
worried about these guys turned out to
be a war party of the unless that was
their plan their plan Oh Dolores slowly
go over there and tire their arms out by
shaking them until the next morning
they're so sore and weakened then they
could be taken advantage and Katherine
well yeah we're you just cut anything
off they won't be able to move their
arms yeah so it turns out this was a war
party of Erica's Mandans
and a minute Therese three hundred
warriors who were fighting the Sumer
this really madness yeah given weapons
as the guys
we were fighting okay the same tribes
hunted promised the Sioux he wouldn't
trade with and then he traded with them
of course the chief said they had to
have something to prove they had met the
white man and hunt gave them a cask of
gunpowder a bag of bullets and three
Devon dozen knives by the way imagine a
time in history when Native Americans
say they want proof that the white man
was there not very early on very early
in relations chief was super happy with
all this and now mr. Lisa's group from
the rival Fur Company caught up and the
two parties camped about a hundred yards
apart awkward Lisa wanted them to travel
together
mr. Lisa invited Pierre to dine on his
boat okay and he gave him whiskey well
no no soup is not fair don't kiss a
gremlin wet you know the deal when me
sister Lisa thought Pierre was
sufficiently buzzed he asked payer
appeared a quit Huntz Gruber for him
again gladly oh this is good
and I'm glad we could bury the hatchet
as far as all the other whiskey stuff
goes no they're still paying for that I
there's oh well that's cool guys more
whiskey now I don't really care about
the problems I'm causing in the future
never tell you about the time I hear my
wife and family into the woods no that's
really a coal there's a good move okay
well actually we don't want it okay
mister Lisa also brought up here's
whisky debt and threatened to forcibly
carry Pierre off in payment for it so
wait now remember we mentioned that he
doesn't like the debt coming up in
conversation yes so but wait so he gets
him on the boat first he says get some
drunk I should work for he says no loads
them up with he's like [ __ ] you you owe
me money yeah you have to work for me
okay so this this job offers turning
it's not changing so they started
arguing and then Pierre punched mr. Lisa
in the face okay good good good this
ought to be fine now Lisa had wanted the
two parties to travel together but this
commotion caused problems and and so
hunt
have done without him and Lisa wanted
them to travel together because they're
going through dangerous those that would
not least somebody took Pierre no Pierre
comes back to mr. right right that's a
and and he wants those off on his own
and hunt wants Leeson hunts group to
travel together because or at least Lisa
wants that yeah doesn't they're going
through dangerous territory things like
the more of us the better yeah you punch
my boy you punch my boy yeah
mr. Ed's party had 82 horses most of
which were packed with goods beaver
traps ammunition corn corn meal and
other necessities sure each of asters
partners had a horse one was designated
to appear to carry his luggage and two
children Marie walked on foot like most
of the men yeah and it's cool too
because she's pregnant and and all the
dudes now super respect her like that
she's not there for a while so Marie was
now close to having the baby and she was
also taking care of two kids two and
five years old and one grown kid no just
two and five no no her husband oh the
younger one she had to carry on her back
carrying a two-year-old a and what's
Pierre doing carrying whiskey he's got
the gun and then the I guess a bottle
yeah sure and a horn great snow came it
was more than knee-deep and after
walking all day they realized they had
only traveled four miles they were now
desperate for food and had to kill and
eat a horse
okay sure December 29th they walked 21
miles through Valley dealing with rain
and snow and they had to cross an icy
stream twice this is the day Maurice
yeah you know going back and forth
streams just don't aren't like a line
yeah yeah okay and this is the day Marie
went into labor Oh perfect
an ice birth oh my god most most people
go for the water one but have you seen a
child allowed and so enjoyed roads
perfectly love it you think they're blue
when they come out quote Pierre treated
the matter as an ordinary occurrence and
no need to cause delay yes yes yeah yeah
alright she's having a baby
it'll slide most of the way he remain by
his wife in the camp with his other
children and his horse and promised to
soon or join the man group
we won't be 5-10 minutes tops she's
really she better be good at this I'll
jump on it if it's taking a while so the
group leaves them sure yeah this again
one of the things I'm like you couldn't
wait for the lady to have a baby no I
mean what look these things can take
hours so the next morning the Dorian
family rejoined the party with a new
baby hey guys we got this screaming
thing she's fine to quote the mother
looked as I'm concerned as if nothing
had happened to her so easy as her
nature in the wilderness when free from
the in fee bling refinements of luxury
so sure she's just digging it like she
had a baby she's cruising right not at
all like she's like quiet because she
wants to [ __ ] kill her husband right
no she's excited for the new chapter of
having another mouth to feed on this
journey what a great what a great trying
time to be starving and killing horses
it's just it's cool to have another
horse hole down yeah it really is
Huntsman asked for permission to
celebrate the birth and he gave it and
they had a banquet of dogs meat and
horse and maybe a little whiskey I don't
know if they have whiskey at this point
no shame the next day they moved on and
kept the pace for five up for days on
the eighth day the newborn baby died Wow
I mean it's not yeah but right of course
that's why she was mad in the first
phone she chewed a horse I mean at what
age could you chew horse when you're
killing dogs and horses to eat them
that's not the time to be like weak you
know we should have as a baby I don't
know yeah this is baby time yeah
they made it to Fort Astoria on February
15th 1812 quote a shout of joy burst
from each canoe at the long wished for
sight all hands poured from the
settlement to receive and welcomed them
it had been an eleven month journey from
some Jesus Christ good God the Canadian
I mean really imagine no imagine a year
of your life I don't like to travel
coach like coach is a bummer imagine a
year of your life greyhound I mean
[ __ ] imagine great let me tell you
how with this imagine taking a ground
for 12 days
seriously imagine we gotta could could
you could you do it no could you do it
no and she had a baby in her what's nice
about ice for 11 months and kept your
other kids alive
and we couldn't go out a greyhound yeah
no no I think I could you have rich
tastes I could not gonna grab your -
laughing the if you live that country
club life I'd really do yeah you love
that gated community life oh my god not
there was getting my Range Rover and
drive around of course this is mine the
Canadian of voyagers went crazy to see
their friends quote it was almost
ludicrous to behold these comrades
hugging and kissing each other on the
riverbank they celebrated the entire day
at the fort they shot guns and had a
feast of fish beaver venison and dog
meat I'll tell you what I've got a bit
of a taste for dog
anyone I love a bit of retriever raw ROM
was issued to the men rum was issued
issuing rum the night ended with a grand
dance by the Canadian of voyagers quote
as usual yes of course but things would
not go well at the fort by summer of
1813 Astor decided to give up on the
Trading Post
because 61 men had died work that's not
the pretty that's up that's it's a chai
that's a lot of man a good amount he
sold the Pacific Fur Company at that
point Marie and Pierre joined up with a
nine man beaver hunting party that
worked for a different Fur Company okay
they built the Trading Post near the
mouth of Idaho's Boise River and several
hunting and trapping camps in the middle
of August 1814 they camped near the
great Snake River where there were a lot
of beepers got to go where the beavers
are it's a good thing we caught the
great Snake River yeah and it's full of
beavers we couldn't call the great
beaver river but it also might be great
snakes there sure
a member of the party mr. Reid built a
house to live in for the winter
okay like mr. Reid Styles [ __ ] going
the only guy is like what do we have a
house yeah that's we got let's make a we
got a lot of things to build a house
with I don't know I was thinking of
burying myself in a close nearby tribes
were nice but when strange tribes pass
by not as great not as friendly they
always asked mr. Reid for guns and
bullets once one shot a horse with an
arrow and stole a canoe interesting
motive not a great horse not necessarily
part of the horses like I am just here I
have no association to the canoe so mr.
Reid built another house farther up the
river was more essential location for
the hunters snows two houses out there
sure late one night in January a
friendly Native American came running to
the house and said some men from the dog
rib tribe had burnt the first house and
were headed their way
singing a war song okay that's not the
best news that's not not the best update
sure was a war song or a baby lullaby no
they were pretty clear they burned that
house and that was all war very specific
doesn't like top ten stuff no no no this
is new stuff okay it was low yeah of
course right and what's joke Murray took
her two kids got on a horse and went to
find Pierre who was out trapping at the
time okay but it was night she got lost
oh dear the next day a storm came so she
sheltered in place Jesus the day after
that she set out again and she saw smoke
rising in the direction she was headed I
dare so she hit again think it might be
the dog rib tribe okay that's what I was
thinking that's right so she waits a day
and now she's waited two days she starts
horse starts moving again the next day
as you can't why do you have to go there
she might not eat the horse this is our
hero as she came close to the hut where
Pierre had been hunting a man staggered
out staggers never good
it's people yeah and he approaches her
it's one of their one of the Canadian
hunting voyagers he was wounded and
faint from a loss of blood he
told Marie that Pierre and the other two
choppers had been robbed and murdered
that morning it appears gone is that
true lost the wife-beater he is for sure
he's dead not Jesus Christ Marie put her
wounded the wounded hunter on the horse
and ran into the forest heading back to
mr. Reid's house Jesus Christ
but the hunter couldn't handle the rough
ride on the horse and he fell twice oh
that far by the way [ __ ] this guy this
guy stay on the [ __ ] horse you're
dying
that fall though that first fall you go
the second one you like I think yeah
let's just do it I think this is the
Lord's way of saying you're not ready
for ponies so Marie took him off and
they camp for the day and then he died
that night
she put her kids on the horse and they
headed out much better yes did the kids
on the water
she made it to mr. Reed's house quote
mr. Reed and the men were all murdered
scalped and cut to pieces cut to pieces
this kind of [ __ ] brutal yeah
desolation and horror stared me in the
face I turned from the shocking sight in
agony and despair took to the woods with
my children and horse and passed the
cold and lonely night without food or
fire probably a good feeling Murray
didn't know what to do next
it's not a good time I mean we've all
been there it's just weird yeah the snow
is deep I was very cold they had no food
to try to make the long journey to
safety would be certain death she was
not about to let her children starve and
realize she would have to go into the
house to look for food okay she knew
there was a stock of salted fish but
didn't this is the next house okay but
didn't know if the dog rib men had taken
it also there would there could be one
waiting in the house for more hunters to
return the next morning she wrapped her
kids in her robe and tied up the horse
and left them and went to some ground
above the house to watch and see if
anything was moving okay
so nothing so she went back to her kids
who were now almost frozen high she had
no choice but to make a fire to warn
them even though it was dangerous after
they were warm she rolled them up in the
robe again and headed for the house Oh
God
she found plenty of fish she took as
much as she could carry and headed back
to the kids
they were almost frozen again she
started another fire and then made the
fish the next day she went back to the
house and got more fish but after that
she was too overwhelmed and sat for
three days unable to move
yeah we go I would go fine I would go
cat comb on a second finally she
realized they had to move she packed up
everything on the horse and put the kids
on the top of the load and set out
leading the horse by the reins quote in
this sad and hopeless condition I
traveled through deep snow among the
woods rocks and the rugged paths for
nine days until I and the horse could
travel no more she picked a spot to rest
for the winter what she's hibernating
this she's going into hibernation Wow
all she can do or else she's not gonna
yeah that's killed the horse of course I
mean they all saw this coming I would
have killed the kids - no more pitching
for you and hung its meat on a tree and
smoked it for the winter
then she built a small hut with pine
branches of long grass and moss and
packed around snow to keep it warm she
did not have an axe she did it all with
a knife Wow
she and the kids stayed in the hut for
53 days Oh God good times
I mean I could you imagine let me just
say I would rather die than be in a hut
with a three-year-old for 53 days but at
least you horse to eat the [ __ ]
non-stop just the repeating of sentences
same story Oh
so
so it's still snowing they start back
out again now they gotta move okay
on the second day she became snow blind
man I was hoping she's had to stay in
place without moving for three days oh
wow it's a good time her supplies were
exhausted she got some of her sight back
and started to move again she got out of
the mountains and down into the plains
she had now been walking for 15 days
they barely had eaten anything for six
days
once on the plane she saw smoke some
ways away but she couldn't carry her
children anymore so she wrapped them in
her robe and hid them okay kids
seems like you used to hide kids a lot
back in it yeah yeah I mean that would
be great if you could do that now just
put him in a like towel for a minute
stash him for the afternoon go to Ikea
come out there is she then set out to
reach whatever Native American camp was
a head quote I was so weak that I could
hardly crawl and I had to sleep on the
way she got to the camp the next day at
noon
it belonged to the Walla Walla tribe
they were very kind to her and
immediately headed out to find her
children they found them and brought the
kids back that night Miranda kids stayed
there for two nights and then started
heading down the river was some of the
Walla Walla a traveler in the area quote
one day I was too tired to ride
horseback so I reembarked in my canoe
about eight o'clock we passed a little
river and saw three canoes the persons
in which were struggling with their
paddles to overtake us we heard a
child's voice cry out in French at at a
Onate stop stop we landed ashore and saw
in one of the canoes the wife and
children of a man named Pierre Dorian it
was the Indians of Walla Walla who had
brought her to us
he gave some presents to the Walla Walla
for their help and took Mary and her
children to Fort a kanigan it's strange
that she's going to a place called I
can't again it was a fur trading outpost
in Washington State they survived Wow
and they started their life over around
1818 Marie married again to Monsignor of
in the year
they had a daughter Marguerite in 1819
but then he died
right after that and Murray married
again in 1824 she will find a winner -
John - pin who was an interpreter at
Fort nez perce they had a son and
daughter maria was called madame iowa
she lived for ten years in the town of
kaiser near Salem Oregon and she died on
September 3rd 1850 the location of her
grave had been lost her newborn who died
was the first white first child with
white ancestry born in Oregon Wow that's
what it used to be like
now imagine Hugh glass with children yes
she's a bit of a badass yeah that is I
mean that like I always think that the
will disturb like I don't know that will
to survive like and maybe it's just the
time maybe were so spoiled now that
you're just like I can't do it cousin I
don't think I I don't think I could do
that I was reading about it recently and
some quote scholars think that women and
women seem to survive longer in these
circumstances because of their children
yeah that me I would that would not
surprise me
whereas dudes are like I'm gonna sit in
the snow and I gotta run from whiskey
I'm running from a whiskey nightmare
uh boy that's crazy yeah stressing me
out
that's wrist yeah a little bit yeah she
made it everybody made it except for the
baby yeah I don't care about the dudes
yeah pairs are [ __ ] dead well he got
he got his yeah I did get his you know
it just wasn't worth it I just don't
know what wasn't to go out and [ __ ]
kill animals and saw the fur it just
doesn't well what's it really is
interesting because it is like you know
it is the root of what we deal with now
which is that we over harvest for yeah
money in the moment that is long term
foolish that's the P it's the beginning
of that stuff you know it's just sort of
like I mean that's really what I mean I
can't I think we were talking about I
don't know four your time with us on the
show or not but like
if if white people didn't get America
what we did what would it what would it
be it'd be fascinating to have another
be fascinating have an area that was
that large that was just living the way
the indigenous people live and you could
see the difference and you'd be like oh
well that works yeah the other thing
doesn't well even I mean black the white
man all day but yeah I mean it's still I
mean it still is yeah it still is very
much it's like that but just know on
steroids yeah it's good it is good right
it's good ma'am it's good it's good it's
a good good times coming it's good all
right well we're saying whoever pelted
Elton
we sent pelts turn off the light turn